[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt und herzlich willkommen bei unserem
format zu gast bei sally ich weiß ist es
schon ewig lange her und eigentlich
hatten wir zwischendurch echt viele
gäste aber in der ersten folge war es
was da und wir haben dieses format
irgendwie wir haben es einfach ein
bisschen nebenbei liegen lassen wir
hatten echt mit jedem gast dieses format
spielen müssen denn wir kochen gemeinsam
kommt manchmal singen wir auch gemeinsam
dann gibt es noch spiele und ul und
heute habe ich einen gast der selber
profi in diesem gebiet ist er ist
nämlich youtuber aber nicht nur
irgendein youtube sondern wirklich einer
der erfolgreichsten und ich muss sagen
einer der hässlichsten wir haben uns
bisher tatsächlich ein einziges mal nur
gesehen aber wie es so war es war echt
so ein bisschen liebe auf den ersten
blick denn wir haben super gut
verstanden sofort die kontakte
ausgetauscht nur leider ist es echt
schon zwei jahre her dass wir uns
gesehen haben ihr willst die ganze
situation corona und so weiter und so
fort es hat nicht funktioniert aber
jetzt sei endlich da hier ist
was
[Applaus]
ich war ein bisschen aufgeregt muss ich
sagen das bekommst weil ich mein ich
weiß wird aus dem rollstuhl sitzt das
wissen wir alle und dann war ich so ok
liebe kommt und ich möchte mit dem
kochen und backen jetzt ist meine frage
ich meine meine küche ist sehr auf mich
abgestimmt ich bin ein relativ großer
mensch hat eine extra hohe küche was
jetzt nicht nur für dich sondern auch
für murat schon im alltag ein problem
ist weil jeden tag schimpft das mich an
die ganzen schränke kommt und an die
gläser und dann sagt ja immer kommt es
halt dann selber weg wie es bei dir zu
hause
also ich habe mir meine küche nicht
selber ausgesucht aber ich habe ein
bisschen glück gehabt weil ich zum
beispiel keine hoch schränke haben wie
du jetzt die gibt es bei uns gar nicht
das ist bei uns zu hause auch schwierig
weil man mein bruder der mit mir
zusammen wohnen zwei meter großes also
noch mal kommen kurse als du und der
muster einheit mit mir zusammen im oder
unten die gläser und ein herr holen die
arbeitsplatte ist aber auch bei mir
ähnlich hoch war es okay nicht optimal
ist aber auch kein drama weil man lernt
ja auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen
sich dann auf zu essen und so ein
bisschen mit zu kochen es gibt aber
natürlich auch extra tiefe küchen und
die werden für mich ideal das
allerwichtigste ist aber für den
rollstuhlfahrer aus meiner sicht platz
zu haben sich drehen zu können
hier überall dran zu kommen sondern das
ist das wichtigste weil wir früher auch
eine ganz kleine küche hatten und da
wenn du dann über stecken bleibt das
nervt und ich glaubwürdig wäre ja auch
ganz gut wenn die arbeitsplatte und
stück weit raus kommen würden dass du so
ein bisschen ranfahren dass wir auch was
du dich nicht und reden muss wer also
eine verlängerte ja ja ich glaube es
wäre ein bisschen schonen da auch für
die wirbelsäule und alles was sonst
stehst du immer so seitlich und muss zu
arbeiten ich muss aber auch ganz ehrlich
sein zu arbeiten
also manchmal verirrt ich mich dahin
aber klar große schöne küche und
manchmal kocht dann auch jemand aber
dass ich okay okay wer kocht und meine
freundin kommt sehr gerne mal vorbei und
kocht aber
ist wirklich so ein thema was man
berücksichtigen muss grad wenn man so in
der küche ich mache viele küchen
planungen und da geht es wirklich um
ergonomische höhe und jetzt erwische ich
mich selber dabei wie ich in meinem
ersten türkischen video auch hier bei
der küche bei der einrichtung gesagt
habt ergonomische höhe ist alles so
zwischen knie und brust aber nicht für
jeden das muss man natürlich dann
bedenken weil man sich eine eigene küche
baut sondern würde ich daher erwarten ja
gut ich habe mir jetzt überlegt wir
kochen was zu sagen wir sind so deine
koch und back skills sind dann auch so
eher rudimentär
ja es wird heute freunde okay ich bin
schon auf die kommentare gespannt ich
habe ihn auch gefragt so immer mal was
ist dein lieblingsessen und dann kam so
nudelauflauf und mensch weißt ja ja das
reicht ich bin auch wenn sehr genügsam
er ist also weil ich mich so gut kochen
kann bin ich sehr froh bin ich
irgendwann mal was probieren darf und
das schmeckt in der regel viel besser
als mainz also ja du probierst auch gern
neues super gerne ja ich hab ich den
kopf zerbrochen was machen wir heute was
machen wir heute und jetzt hab ich mir
gedacht was wir gehen jetzt raus heute
wirklich noch richtig schönes wetter in
die outdoor küche und dann machen wir
zusammen
so ein richtig leckeres gulasch was auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt gibt so ein bisschen
zungenbrecher dena gulasch
ist so mit sauerkraut ist winterlich
weihnachtliche und dann packen wir brot
dazu und dann gibt es noch einen
nachtisch er muss ja sagen die
weihnachten steht kurz vor der tür oder
fenster
und mein team hat wieder für heute
spiele und quiz und fragen vorbereitet
also ich muss auch sagen ich weiß auch
nicht was auf uns zukommt fairerweise
die alles
gemacht
als ich habe unsere outdoor küche waren
würden und ja ziemlich nagelneues ja ist
ja auch also wer weint jetzt heute
zusammen ein also die küche hier wurde
jetzt gerade fertig aber jetzt kommt der
winter aber zum grillen gibt zwar keine
jahreszeit und jetzt wo die sonne
scheint haben uns gedacht gemacht
optimales wetter wie auch sein und jetzt
sogar einen aufzug ein lift er ist
unfassbar für so eine terrasse ja also
es war bei uns im team tatsächlich so
währungs sagt wir machen das weil wir
auch diesmal empfangen wollen und auch
mal andere gäste und besucher weiß halt
nie und wenn halt jemand da ist im
rollstuhl dann willst du die person hat
auch integrieren ohne dass es irgendwie
krass ausfällt und klar man muss sagen
die teile die sind super und
besonders schön sind das ist praktisch
und funktional auflösung haben das ja
auch so bestehen mit offenen gegeben
dass es noch richtig stylisch wird dass
man so etwas überall integriert dass
keiner mehr sagt das stört irgendwo als
statthalter auf man hat ja ihr habt euch
jemand ein bisschen gegen die ästhetik
oder dafür für die für mich und alle
anderen gastfreundschaft und auch für
unser team ich mal mehr wachsen ja auch
ständig und dann kann es auch sein dass
hier jemand arbeitet im rollstuhl und
dann will ich dass die person über
integriert ist ja super es ist die stufe
ihr natürlich noch ein bisschen hoch wie
mache ich fahre das ganz hohe hauke also
ich denke das team von rolf die das
gebaut haben der sich bemüht das ist
ganz ganz schnell geht weil wir gesagt
haben jetzt bald gäste da ja direkt die
outdoor küche einweihen wird freue mich
grüßen hinaus wird soll ich runter ja
perfekt
ich will schon das ist auch schon alles
vorbereitet
dass wir hier schön drücken kann machen
ist auch schon da sie bedeutet uns immer
bestimmte dahin nichts weg ist unser
haus und hof katze
das immer großartig chor ebenerdig
eine richtige grill küche ja da freue
ich mich jetzt schon drauf auf alle
sommer auf alle winter auf alle
jahreszeiten egal was wenn wir jetzt
genau machen also wir werden jetzt in
kohlers kochen auf dem grill dann packen
wir brötchen dazu und als nachtisch
gibt's noch ein apple crumble so ein
winterlich weihnachtliche okay also ich
versuche natürlich zu helfen wo es nur
irgendwie geht aber ich bin nicht der
talentierteste ist das kriegen wir hin
das ist alles recht easy und ich würde
sagen ich noch kurz die zutaten her und
später gibt es auch community fragen ob
ich habe gestern in der community einige
sammeln und das machen wir später noch
ruhig mit also ich checke kurz alles
ok also jetzt gibt's gulasch eigentlich
wollte ich etwas vegetarisches machen
aber wenn du den murat kennst dann weißt
du da ist weil das nach das
funktionieren hat und bevor ich mir dann
das gemecker anhalt denke ich mir so
komm lass uns gut machen oder so machen
wir das also haben wir schon mal gulasch
fleisch das ist schon geschnitten dann
zwiebeln knoblauch eine kartoffel zum
binden saure sahne tomatenmark olivenöl
dann in diesem see gardena gulasch immer
sauerkraut
grad mag oder nicht hier ist alles und
rinder schinken oder gewürze gemüsebrühe
genau was genau binde die kartoffel was
war und die kartoffeln die bindet diese
soße später half ja es ist so ein
bisschen dick mäßiger und logisch war
eine testfrage auf ich kann mir genau
also was wir machen können du kannst
gerne schon mal wenn uns zwiebeln
schälen und schneiden
gleichwohl vielleicht ganz großes manson
hat ist eigentlich hierzu zählen ganz
cool
und wir gehen schon mal zusammen
angrillen den habe ich nämlich schon
vorgeheizt und habe auch schon im bus
eisentor eingestellt damit er einfach
schön heiß wird und dann wird es darin
gleich geschmort okay
ich mache das halt so wie ich denke
kommt sondern mit fingernägel und sogar
zu machen geht schnell als am besten
hier hinten an dieser da wo eigentlich
der stromklau dran ist und dann kannst
du hier also viele machen es tatsächlich
so ich weiß nicht ob es glaube ich eine
stimmige zeit de mar und tauschte auch
schon gezeigt es kommt jetzt jeder
einmal durch die schule ja die wurzel
hier die lassen wir dran weil er weil
die hält die zwiebel wenn du dir nämlich
gleich schneidest dann ist bei vielen so
die eine führung dahin die anderen
dorthin können diese wurzeln die hält es
so zusammen ginge also lassen wir dran
und 4c studios dazu unter druck ich frag
mich immer wie viele hautschichten davon
eigentlich nur die äußerste und ich
hatte im studium und hauswirtschaft
studiert auf lehramt und unsere dozentin
war sehr streng war auch sehr schwäbisch
und hat immer gesagt wirklich nur die
äußerste weg weil das ist ein
lebensmittel oder aber es hat alles
andere der lebensmittelverschwendung
mal eigentlich kann man nur das trockene
hier nicht okay gut dann macht mal
drüben war ich versuche mich hier an
erzählt
das nehme ich mit und ich nämlich mit
das sieht richtig gut aus na ja wahnsinn
doch das als hättest du sagen ich will
die äußerste schicht treffen deshalb
dauert es
richtig schwäbisch sparsam aber hier ist
alles schon mal gut vorgeheizt jetzt
olivenöl rein
und dann einfach das fleisch anbraten so
entwickeln sich gut die rest aromen und
später darf dem kind dann schön
durchschmoren
celtic road perfekt das wasser sehr gut
jetzt halbieren und einfach grob
schneiden und beim fleisch achtet ihr am
besten immer darauf dass fleisch nicht
ganz kalt ist aus dem kühlschrank
sondern so ein bisschen raumtemperatur
angenommen hat denn wir wollen ja dass
das cola staat wird und wenn du
praktisch kaltes fleisch in die heiße
pfanne haus dann clips ganz zählen
das wusste ich auch nicht
mal das bisschen anbraten und die
zwiebeln da kann ich nichts falsch
machen also einfach ganz grob und das
große geben werke genau dann die
knoblauchzehe auch schon mal
stand ich immer so ein bisschen an macht
sie dann klein was mache ich mit dem dem
kopf bleibt einfach dran ist wieder
zurück also eigentlich anders rum aber
das macht nichts genau schneider was so
weiter weil bei dir es der kopf noch das
ist ja dann habe ich so weg das tue was
du dich jetzt
das ganze ich habe einen vergleich noch
kleiner ein erhöhtes passt aber guckt
uns am besten hier sind diese wurzel und
am besten machst du sowieso von der
richtung in der richtung
denn jetzt noch besser kommt genau
so ich bin hier draußen muss sagen es
ist immer schön hier zu grillen aber du
musst mich noch ein bisschen ein leben
also so werkzeug und sowas braucht man
hier draußen das ist so ein bisschen her
ich denke dass das erste mal richtig
und dann kannst du die die kannst du
einfach so mit dem messer sowie sohn
zerdrücken und dann kann man die leicht
schälen so pass auf deine finger auf
drogen erwarten vielleicht geht es
anders sonst aber
okay so ich mit so richtig mit schwung
aber die ist echt
also die soll kaputt gehen
mein gott dann müsste ich das
gehört und die knoblauchzehe einfach so
grob schneiden und dass die
zwiebelwürfel scheiben spalten gebe ich
schon mal mit auf dem grill ok
[Musik]
das
brot und dann nehmen wir eigentlich
alles mit rüber also auch die
gemüsebrühe
oh ja dann den rinder schinken den
kannst du vielleicht noch so grob in
stücke schneiden
das ist unser kopf und das auch noch
genau das kommt auch gleich sein
da komm ich bin schon das geht schon
nicht so schlecht aus wie ich das mache
also ich bin wirklich ich mir graut es
schon vor dem tor den kommentaren aber
hab nachsicht ich bin heute auch
wirklich extra hier weil ich weiß dass
mir hier einiges beibringen kann
vielleicht noch ein bisschen seine
finger schützen also wenn du die so hin
streckt und dann echt einem messer marge
dann anfällig ist ja schon eine so
extrem noch nicht aber ich kann echt
kein blut sehen möchte aber du kannst
deine finger nicht so sondern so
genau
man sich davor den die finger schneidet
ist schweres feuer abend
also als der sturm ist sich hier mal
verletzt hat
ist er umgefallen so bisschen auch nicht
so faul und ich fast hinterher als ich
konnte noch keine ich kann kurz erste
hilfe leisten aber danach bin ich kaputt
okay danach bin ich gebe mir mühe mich
nicht zu verletzen noch würfeln oder
bleibt ich finde dass sport ja dann
sowieso und dann wird es eh alles
relativ klein groß stand heraus
und das thema auch gleich mit ganz
ehrlich mit dem grill
die manchmal ganz zum schluss rein was
war nochmal ist kartoffeln so ein
bisschen reiben wie gesagt die stärke in
der kartoffel die binde das gericht und
die reibereien
[Musik]
ich stelle die frage wann muss ich meine
kartoffeln eigentlich schälen und wann
nicht also wir machen uns oft so bei
neuen kartoffeln die schema nicht die
haben so eine ganz dünne schale die
lassen wir einfach dran die kartoffeln
bei uns aus dem garten ist mein auto
schon drin generell sollte man sich
schon stehlen weil es einfach viele
stoffe enthalten die der körper nicht so
aufnehmen kann aber gelegentlich
kartoffelschalen essen ist okay okay ich
glaub schon mal sagen das nicht
übertreibt und generell nicht zu viel
davon ist alles okay okay deswegen ist
die dose die dosis macht's commerzbank
macht das so da rein und
auch zu diesem gulasch gibt es
verschiedene rezepte also das ist jetzt
echt so ein bisschen die sally variante
mit diesem türkischen hinterschinken
tomatenmark und so können die zuschauer
das auch nachkommen na klar da gibt es
das rezept dann in der app und
schauen also wer die noch nicht runter
geladen hat er verpasst
das nehme ich jetzt konnte man geht mit
gerne genau weiß ich schon richtig gut
vor und
es riecht gut na ja also dann kommen
jetzt alle zutaten rein ich weiß dass
jetzt auch ein pass auf dass sich nicht
verbrennt wenn du irgendwann kommst
[Musik]
also da jetzt auf gießen mit gemüsebrühe
wer will kann auch mit rotwein ablöschen
es gibt natürlich auch noch meinen
geschmack und der kräftige farbe und
dann kommen jetzt noch gewürze reihen
salz verfahren bis in paprika muskat und
dann lassen wir fahren jetzt einfach
eine stunde sport
machen in der zwischenzeit brötchen
nicht jammern brettchen dazu wird
richtig lecker
[Musik]
ich hab so ein bisserl einfacher gemacht
dass wir draußen nicht noch kneten nun
alles müssen ich habe schon mal teig
vorbereitet
ja noch mal einfach so eine mischung von
uns genommen das heißt damit machen wir
die brötchen
und vielleicht siehst du das in
röstzwiebeln drin
ja eigentlich jetzt auch
nicht wie ich liebe dich so war es nicht
raus also beim besten willen aber okay
das heißt das machen wir jetzt genau das
teilweise
so seine mischung für so ein großes brot
aber dort nowitzki jahr geht auch
schnell auf dem grill und es schön
handlich
im detail noch mal
süße kleine
brötchen und die werden jetzt einfach
rund geformt genau da kannst du die
hände falls das klingt so ein bisschen
mailen und sein ist eigentlich wichtig
von außen nach innen so ein bisschen
falken das ist eine glatte oberfläche
kriegt von aktien ein bisschen folgen
und mich sehr viel mehr an das ist keine
armee lässt ihn gibt und dann kann man
die nämlich so schleifen
ok rate ich mich irgendwie überlegt
ich habe das ganze die ganze form
zerstört wird sich glaub ich so viel
mehr drin das ist nicht ehrlich ich hab
ne
hatte also
genau es ist also flache jetzt praktisch
immer so und das immer in die mitte zu
einem punkt genau
aber es wird da ist ja jetzt nicht
runter ja ja sag mal erwarte was habe
ich falsch finde dass ich weiß es nicht
ich gucke nicht auskommen so wartet die
kugeln hätte ich auch so
kommen wir probieren es nochmal also
damit an die hände so ein bisschen
bisschen nicht zu viel richtig achtet
immer darauf den fehler machen viele
aber nicht zu viel mehr so jetzt kannst
dich ja so die spitze
die spitze rein und raus und soeben
überzeugt ist im gegenuhrzeigersinn
total
okay
die ecke ist noch nicht drin ja jetzt so
noch von außen immer das brett ist so
ok
die wird jetzt glatt siehst du
das hg das ist magie und dann dreht er
nämlich die unterseite nach oben
sie sitzt oben genau und nimmst ich weiß
nicht so recht linkshänder richtung und
dann kann es mit der rechten hand so und
die finger die formen das jetzt so genau
so die formen so den kloß nach unten und
da wird das blatt ok also wir wollen
kreisrunde brötchen ja kein du kannst du
auch warum wie du willst aber sowie
teilt die oberfläche schön und die
größte gut und dann gehen die ihnen auf
und damit man mit schiff und
dann machen gleich noch ein traumbild
vom grill und alles was wir hier machen
geht natürlich auch auf dem herd
backofen
aber ich bin draußen auf dem grill hat
es halt zum einen anderen geschmack und
zum anderen ist es einfach schön ja es
ist gerade mal stand ich bin echt
gespannt wie es einem schmeckt muss in
baku
weil das hier praktisch mit der outdoor
küche hast du eigentlich alles in einem
auf so einem big green egg der hass und
herd backofen ist alles ja ein grill
alles in einem und
brötchen und brote sind
dass wir so ein dampfbad offen weil der
dann sind die feuchtigkeit nicht raus
lässt und dann trocknet die auch nichts
aus
könnt ihr euch mal angedacht wieso auch
hochzeit
[Gelächter]
das kennen wir doch
[Musik]
was machst du da jetzt hat die steilwand
kurz einmal kann sie auf platzen lassen
oder einschneiden einstein ist schön ich
kenne das von diesen glauben ja genau
deswegen dann nimmt man die
oberflächenspannung so ein bisschen weg
und da haben auch gleich ein schönes
muster eigentlich müssten sie jetzt noch
mal kurz auf gehen aber das funktioniert
auch so ganz gut dagegen vorher wird auf
der iss auch schon war
die backen wir jetzt einfach auf den
pizza stein auf einen pizzaschneider mit
gravur kann man so auflegen ich gucke
jetzt mal ganz passt
ich dachte weil kurz zu heiß aber es
passt also hab ich noch nie wer kommt
haben wir dann noch mit rein taktisch
perfekt und zu und wie lange dauert das
jetzt ist er 20 minuten
zeit genug um ein spiel zu spielen das
spiel ich weiß nicht ach so okay das ist
alles so und ich muss meinen team fragen
okay frage die ich werde jetzt auch über
überrascht spielen wir
mal gucken wer das spiel master ist
jetzt kommt unser spiel master sarah
spiel meisterin wir reden ja
es tut mir echt leid ich habe dir gar
keine fragen gestellt ich habe meinen
zuschauern nicht wirklich denn lieber
vorgestellt aber wir unseren koch
prozent tatsächlich stehe immer fragen
und jetzt beim kochen musste ich dich
was fragen das ist vorbei so
interessiert und dann wollte ich dich da
auch nicht bremsen und wir machen das
noch ja dann im podcast ja auch also ein
podcast dürft euch gerne anhören und
jetzt jetzt kommt sarah
ja das war schon super gemacht
[Musik]
so wollte er sagen so der stefan raab
der aber nichts wissen
sein
fazit zum spiel fand
ok aber was hat das mit liedern zu gern
ja aber ich werde niemals öffentlich
singen weil das möchte ich niemandem
antun
kochen
und dem der erste
wahl
okay
[Gelächter]
jetzt weiß ich wie der hase läuft hier
ist ein abgekartetes spiel ja aber ich
jede stelle einfach schnell sinkt ja
einfach raus gerückt
sein
also das ist doch
[Gelächter]
okay zwei punkte mein garten geschenkt
oder so wirklich drei musketiere oh mein
gott
die drei musketiere
heißt es musketiere muss man wissen muss
musketiere musketiere ich muss hier mal
dass
wir werden unsere gruppe ins spiel
gebracht er muss ganz irre
ja ja weil wir drei sind doch die
musketiere
du kannst es noch hätten es war alles
absicht
war richtig jetzt
extra noch mal gegoogelt wer sich
getraut
als sie mit musketen bewaffnet war
kein wunder haben doch keine christen
geworden du bist einem guten weg häuser
musikspiele
karaoke vorteil
mein lied ja ob
er von den drei musketieren werde das
ist die gruppe ich habe damals im film
ok ok mit dem und mit nächsten sollte
mit rein da nicht aber nicht mit rein
und zwar etwas mit elton john und mit
dem weiß wo du meinst du mir daraufhin
stimme du musst zu weltweit wohnzimmer
echt ja die haben auch so bin ich bin da
so abgeht aber die haben eine riesige
musik wirst du wärst das zum ja wirklich
meine freundin geschminkt daher kommt ja
ladet sie mal angefasst
0 23
ich hatte nicht mal eine idee wo
[Musik]
irgendwo drin in diesem in diesem lied
ist auf jeden fall läuft dann bin ich
mir ziemlich sicher dies muss im titel
sein
da gab's ein
von dem was nicht
okay sind deutscher rap song und läuft
das gibt's doch nicht
es gibt sagt sonja ist es nochmals
live view
ich weiß nicht mehr wieder geht gerade
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt schon mit sechs punkte
von ganz anfang
das ist eigentlich auch so
was schon oh mein gott ich
habe meine sprache gehabt noch nicht
sagen es waren alle englischen wörter
und da kann ich einfach anders verloren
doch diesmal kommt die kunde
erzählt mir kein deutsches
[Gelächter]
herz
mein herz es schlägt wenn ich dich sehe
so ein ehrenpunkt mit gewohnt
großartig großartig
war das prämierte ja ja das ist ja das
ist gerade der wecker klingelt die
bekannt gute timing du bist raus weil
wir müssen jetzt droht ein schrittchen
angucken
zufrieden dann brauchen sie noch
braucht ist wegen fünf minuten
wie lange dauert das zweite spiel
perfekt machen
das nächste geht schnelligkeit
antworten okay okay der der als erstes
die richtige antwort hat haben den punkt
ok anstrengten willst du wissen ja okay
das ist hat zwei und wasserstoff wasser
ja in welchem land wurden die meisten
menschen in china auf welchem kontinent
liegt die wüste sahara grafiker nicht
wenn wir wegen sich schneller als
schallwellen richtig oder falsch richtig
welche ist der links die küste welt der
amélie
lang ist ein wahrer von
42,5
welches hier ist das größte der welt
denn was ist los hatte schon zum portal
chip kampf und ach so ja
sie machen
musik musiker kämpfe
genau da näher dran ist wie viele
reiskörner sind in 500 gramm reis und
einer 500 gramm reis verteidigung wer
hat die abgewählte schon und die erste
frage weil die person hat doch zu viel
zeit in den 500 das abholen und dann
runter gebrochen
[Musik]
das nicht dass
jetzt hat gewonnen weil es ja mal ich
hab gesagt vom bauchgefühl hätte ich
10.000 gesagt aber weil sie so niedrig
war dadurch in bodenmais aufschreiben
ach so wie wahrscheinlich sind die
nächsten gemäß teil wird aufgeschrieben
was kommt jetzt der regeln genau nächste
chefs frage ja wie groß ist die
entfernung zwischen waghäusel und new
york in kilometern okay
ist das nenne ich die route regelmäßig
das okay ich bin fertig
ich habe 9000 kilometer
ach so du fliegst andersrum sally ach so
du fliegst über die andere route jetzt
verstehe ist okay das war
okay
danke schön
die letzte frage wie viele
weihnachtsbäume in deutschland pro jahr
verkauft
muss man mit mit
ich habe eingeloggt
kannst du ins wasser drücken
millionen 60 millionen
aber ich finde wenn du jetzt überlegt 80
millionen menschen
mit 530 millionen okay der menschen
nicht so viele haushalte du hast aber an
so sie tragen dann gibt's noch auf dem
markt hat ein musiker kurs die kein kauf
nehmen weil die entfernen lassen sieht
es wieder runter ja ja aber 30 trotzdem
merken
auch kunst oder kunststoff
und in einer sekunde
ich bin gut getimt perfekt
es hat perfekt gepasst
so
richtig schön bist du zufrieden ja also
brötchen sind gut ja gulasch gucken wir
noch kurz rein ich lass dir noch perfekt
so jetzt geht's ans eingemachte
gemachte und eingekocht war auch vor
also sieht gut dass
das sieht nicht nur gut aus
das riecht
doch ich glaube da können wir jetzt
probieren
[Musik]
als gulasch ist fertig und jetzt aber
noch unser apple crumble da drauf weil
da können wir jetzt schon mal ein essen
und danach dass das ergebnis so einen
hunger
und ich erst okay max probieren ja ich
bin schon sehr gespannt wo sind
gespannt
ich mag ja so einfach so einfach ist die
welt für mich schon viel zu kompliziert
gewicht aber einfach nur kein fleisch
schneiden zwiebeln alles anbraten in
topf schon fertig du musst nichts machen
das kann nichts schief laufen sagt das
nicht so einfach meine finger gesehen
die ich mir fast abgeschnitten haben
aber kommt es ein bisschen sauer gerne
zum schwurgericht und je länger es sport
umso größer wird
das schon
ich bin gespannt wie das jetzt schmeckt
dürfen probieren ja ich hab ich hab's
nicht versalzen weil ich bin schon immer
so der große salz habe ich auch ich hab
ja gott sei dank
was soll jetzt gar nicht wie lange es
jetzt auf dem herd oder einenkel
aber man kann sagt ich noch länger
darauf lassen da passiert wächst das ist
großartig und
ich bin ein teil davon gewesen dass das
was ich immer noch dass ich mal ein so
ein fan
das projekt dauert probieren ich darf
das skoda wie hast du das jetzt
geschafft dass das fleisch genau diesen
richtigen punkt erwischt hat
wir haben einfach für alles andere lange
gebraucht
das ist ein trick also wenn man so eine
stunde sport ist gut zwei stunden ist
noch besser aber ich fand das war jetzt
schon ich glaube eine stunde was drauf
das perfekt der die brötchen sind ja
richtig gut
da wo jetzt gleich mal das team dazu
übrigens die ganzen fragen die aus der
community kamen das machen wir
tatsächlich podcast also hört euch gerne
den podcast an der cap bei uns jeden
donnerstag online genommen denn
praktisch morgen der kommt morgen online
und dann erfahrt ihr da einfach noch
genaueres über den level
glaube wir haben jetzt sarah ist doch
ein spiel hast du noch ein spiel hat sie
noch das große finale und zum abschluss
kommt ok ich 22 spiele und
unserem großen finale gibt es dann noch
ein apple crumble
schon so oma essen ist so das beste
essen finde ich gemacht von oma oder ein
gericht von einem gericht von oma ja
also für mich gilt gilt so egal was er
macht das was raus kommt meistens
wirklich super super aber ja die
gerichte man kann versuchen die
nachzukochen sie werden aber nie genau
so werden also samira sagt auch
tatsächlich zu mir immer alles was oma
kocht noch besser als bei mir und ich
muss damit gefühlt sich daran es ist ok
weil es meiner mama ist aber es schmerzt
schon im herzen
was soll ein absolutes lieblingsgericht
von zu hause das wäre ein gericht von
meiner oma die hat nämlich immer größer
gemacht dass mit braten und das
thüringer trio wird ja auch gut dazu
doch das ist einfach so ein wärmendes
sättigen des leckeres essen
war oder ist die
usa massiv und
ich nicht gut
[Musik]
hat geschmeckt nun es schmeckt es
schmeckt riecht auch traumhaft wir
machen jetzt noch eine fragerunde und
kelly war ja mal zu gast bei wer weiß
denn so was
also keine anstellung sein warum bist du
so
ich habe einmal im team eltern verloren
super dass man könnte jetzt sagen das
hat etwas mit dir zu tun die größe
zungen würden so was hat das mit den
fragen zu tun
die waren auch
weil ich immer im falschen moment auf
dem männer gehört haben
mammuts wird immer die männer
als christin jetzt auch fragen die man
eigentlich nicht wissen kann ok ich gebe
euch drei auswahlmöglichkeiten super und
wieder aufs handy eintippen was ihr wert
und dann sagen sondern gucken wir mal
wer
genau bereit für die erste frage
warum erlauben ist viele gemeinden nicht
biologisch abbaubare und kompostierbare
kunststofftüten in der biotonne zu
entsorgen
die kompostieranlagen können sich nicht
vollständig abbauen
b bei wärme entfalten sie einen geruch
der kleintiere anlockt dein handy
blendet mit crazy
da das ist eine antwortmöglichkeit
bei wärme entfalten sie einen geruch der
kleintier anlockt und c sie verbinden
sich oft zu großen harten klumpen
habe eingeloggt ja
[Musik]
beide zu töten
darum
richtig richtig ist es die
kompostieranlagen findet sich nie
vollständig abbauen
dann stimmt doch was mit der folie nicht
ja eben habe ich die welt das ist
quatsch getrieben das heißt
das war jetzt gut rechts dagegen einen
großen haken wichtig
welches zuvor selten gibt legt die
hochzeit sekunde und schreibt wieder
drin liegt nicht an mir ich habe gelesen
welche zuvor selten gibt legt die
hochzeits tradition macht die queen
victoria von england populär so was
kannst du wissen also das ist doch nicht
die bunte
[Gelächter]
sich als brautpaar mit reis beworfen zu
lassen
ein weißes brautkleid zu tragen und c
scheppernde konservendose num hochzeits
wagen zu befestigen
queen victoria also die würde die
tradition wurde zuvor seltener gepflegt
die jetzt ist es eigentlich schon
darf das sagen weil queen victoria
ist
ja ja die zweite also mein gott dann
aber doch nicht so relevant für die
antwort ja doch echt ja doch mal dann
wird das ist herrlich man sagen so
weißes kleid gibt es vielleicht schon
länger unter wasser essig oder reis oder
kurz google nein hört dann sagen wir
sind ein block
[Musik]
dann muss ja von wann steht noch mehr
details dazu als erster quizshows muss
ja ja also kein pflaumer erklärte es
dann schon weiter ist ja auch schon
länger in der branche
hast du nicht so ein knopf im ohr im
zweifelsfall kriegt dann glaube ich so 1
verwerten wir beantragen der knopf im
ohr umher
tja da kommen
die andere
wurde frage um algen und moos zu
vermeiden sollte ein gewächshaus
zusätzlich mit oleander pflanzen im
kübel bestückt werden b mit einem
sprühnebel bewässert werden so dass sie
nicht zu dicht an wänden und hecken
stehen
um was im gewächshaus um algen und moos
zu vermeiden
aber ein glocke
schlägt immer ein bisschen fest denn bei
c schon wieder so
richtig bei den punkt perfekt der ich
hätte jetzt gesagt weil dann halt so
schatten drauf kommt oder so
kondenswasser und autogrammen draußen
acht bestimmt hat eine gute erklärung ja
die einfach bei youtube eingeben
auch alle erklärungen leider kein video
vorbereitet
perfekt ist was das ich muss meinen
spieler master fragen wir jetzt gerade
stets
natürlich mit allen spielen gemeinsam
ich habe
spiele ich fahre so
cool da kommen wir jetzt zum großen
thema
ich bin auch immer ein guter verlierer
ich kann damit kommen wir auf
unentschieden ja gewinnen konnte nicht
mehr
doch annas noch so ein paar extra vor
allem
aber die könnten entschieden kurz dann
kein stechen oder sagen
okay genoss die sonne also findet wir
müssen die bälle werfen was er
eigentlich kann wir haben ein behältnis
und ihr habt
das verhältnis den ball werfen
anders
jetzt liegt der druck da
ja
dreimal treffen ja ich hab ich die bälle
okay das war natürlich jetzt noch mal
drei mal werfen oder im neuenburger bild
machen dreimal werfen und dann zu oft
wir halt drin ist ja ok ach so genau
okay da nacheinander
wahrhaft die plätze fertig los von hier
aus weißt du ganz schön wenn du jetzt
den ersten trips dann hab ich druck bis
bis nach mir ja ja und wie viel technik
ist keine 17.500
kannst du nicht
er war nicht schlecht
da wäre das erste mal trifft weil weil
wir uns nicht zutraut dass wir bei drei
mal überhaupt einmal treffen das ist
nicht kommen
das ist jetzt nicht passiert oder ihr
habt sie so wütend gemacht wenn mit der
provokation
okay aber ich darf noch werden
mahnung noch ein noch einmal okay aber
wenn du triffst habe ich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
habe für das unternehmen weil es steht 1
1 ok ja das unentschieden dann brauchen
wir stecken ja mehr zuerst trifft aber
als
dann kommt der teufel los
wie lösen wir das jetzt wir stehen
also jetzt geht es um den gesamtsieg
genau jetzt geht es um den gesamtsieg
das spiel ohne brücke seid ihr bereit
wie groß ist der pazifische ozean
was in milliliter
quadratkilometer ach du kacke also ich
hätte mir einmal die m8 die kacke ich
habe keine hilfe die dahinter hat nicht
mal die frage was
[Musik]
hat dich nicht ich ja nicht alles klar
ein quadratkilometer ja
also ich sag es sind sagt es nicht laut
ich hab schon eingeloggte
quadratmeter kilometer kubikmeter
ich kann nicht über die
oberfläche
hallo mal korrigieren müssen wir jetzt
sprechen
quadrat genau im meta oder kilometer dem
motorrad quadrat wohl nur die oberfläche
das ist ein gutes und jetzt geben die
oberfläche der oberfläche kubik genau
sieht man nicht aber
quadratkilometer oberfläche
ja ich habe noch einmal korrigieren
müssen angelockt das hat sich ja finale
finale eingeladen
quadratkilometern absicht ich habe jetzt
auch eingeloggt mir das jetzt egal
99 millionen 9 108
107 106
kilometer
also ich war bei einer millionen karat
noch einmal korrigiert auf 100000
quadratmeter ich hab keine ahnung
wirklich sagen ja beide so so so falsche
quadrat manager
[Gelächter]
der extremfall schon jetzt weiß ich auch
nicht wenn er dran ist
165 millionen 200.000 quadratkilometern
dabei sehr tor jetzigen oder paar meter
stehen hier stehen wir noch mal drauf
meter 9000 quadratmeter ich habe 100.000
quadratkilometer
wenn ihr nach hause kommt dass das jetzt
mal kurz in die kamera wenn ihr noch mal
kunst passt bloß auf die hielt die ziel
war es ab das ist eine abgekartete
nummer gewesen von anfang an die zahlen
das ist alles wird hier die lachen das
ist jetzt alles ablenkung freunde lasst
euch nicht blenden wenn ihr nachwuchs
kurs auf
ich hatte kilometer und dann habe ich
korrigiert in meter und dann halt
gedacht ach egal ich haben so was nicht
geschätzt du hast ja
man muss nur laut genug schreien dann
gewöhnt waren so was auch das aus der
das gemacht hat ja möglichst vielen dank
ich glaube so eine grundbildung tut und
speisen kochen kannst du das muss ich ja
festhalten jetzt kommt es dass hier sage
es könne nicht richtig sein wir doch
einfach so fest selber machen wir noch
ein auto
[Musik]
jetzt verfestigt doch zusagen geografie
ist nun meine steckt 0 wirklich
nullkommanull deine ja in dem ein spiel
habe ich gemerkt ein bisschen kann ich
das aber eher flächen und größen das
geht ja das könnte ich schon wenn ich
wüsste was wo liegt also ok ja wir
müssen hier und gehören dazu sagen
können so zusammen dann wird's
irgendwann wechseln sondern ein duell
wie ein duett ja aber so jetzt hab ich
schon etwas quatsch ja aber es war echt
lustige folge ps jetzt gleich noch unser
crumble hier ganz gemütlich mit bisschen
kinder politiker wir packen jetzt doch
die heizstrahler aus jetzt wird es doch
ganz schön kalt hier draußen ja ja und
danke auch dass du mein gast warst ja
ich danke dir für die einladung für das
leckere bekochen und dem koch ja
gemeinsam kochen ich habe heute gelernt
wie man zwiebeln schneidet räume leute
wie man brötchen schleift ja schleift
objekt alles also groß ist großes kino
deswegen also hat gern morgen im podcast
reihe erfahrt ihr ganz vieles noch
überlebe vielen dank fürs einschalten
und bis bald war das macht gut und wir
gucken mal nach dem krieg
es ist perfekt wir brauchen noch
geschehen und damit ggf
[Musik]
übrigens gibt es auch für euch einen big
green egg zu gewinnen nämlich den big
green egg minimax der passt auch auf
jeden fall bei euch auf die terrasse
oder den balkon aber da schaue dir gerne
mal auf instagram vorbei denn dort läuft
das gewinnspiel viel glück
[Musik]